welcome to this video this is some round
seven right around seven coverage the
Norway super tournament and I must tell
you right away that this round featured
some very very long games and this
basically means that some of those games
that I'm going to present you yes some
presentation go will seem a bit rushed
simply because if I am trying to say
something on on every move it will be in
an epic epic long video so some some
parts will be somewhat looking like
you're watching a video in fast forward
otherwise this is getting far too long
okay starting with the game swidler
against actor style I got some questions
why I have problems pronouncing the
Norwegian player's name yeah i can tell
you why just to have this fund note them
in the video for some reason for more
than 20 years I thought his name would
actually be spelled otherwise I always
thought his name is actor Stein ad GE
and not a gde and I have to relearn the
name don't ask me why I had it had it
wrong in my head but I always have to
ask myself okay his name is dr. Stein
and not up to Stein whatever let's let's
do it this game swidler against the
Norwegian number two to avoid the
pronunciation issue yes we let the press
conference stated that he couldn't find
anything against actor Stein's French so
he went for the the Reggie flank opening
whatever and pretty quickly we get an
independent position this this type of
position swidler I'm already had on the
board in earlier games 11 being a game
against the chronic that
actually one some years ago and at least
it is assured that we have a complicated
battle here c4 was play to take the
center and after Bishop before it was a
bit inconvenient white really does not
want to to interpose and allow black to
exchange the bishop so King f1 was
played Knight b6 got a trade here and g5
yeah and tears Villa said that he was
surprised that night h5 was played as it
wasn't looking very natural to him yeah
I must admit I've I probably also
wouldn't have expected to the move but
it serves some very interesting purpose
as we see later and this is to introduce
the idea f5 into the position and in
this case the night makes lots of sense
on on h5 yeah after a capture let's say
for example of we look at something like
this and here black could try f5 yeah I
note that check light is very useful
here this is one point of the night on
h5 which was not easy to foresee and in
the game he took on b6 and played Bishop
before which is directly working against
their five i did also protecting d3 yeah
b5 now played a very good universal move
it gets some space black also already
has the rook developed here so that
there's also some always some pressure
on the apron Luke g1 plate we should be
five and queen d 1 yeah and here we have
a funny situation um it is witless
intention here to play queen bee three
the Queen would be nice on b3 keeping an
eye on they have seven point and
threatening bishop g6 and with the Queen
on b3 it's pretty sure that f5 is never
going to happen
so octa Stein is now playing Queen e6
attacking h3 yeah and the best move that
white has in this position is quite
clearly Quincy form and yeah it went
back 21 and you have a sneaky suspicion
and it's the right suspicion day now
drew the game with a repetition which is
yeah a bit of a shame it still looked
like an interesting position and if
anybody maybe black could try to
continue um yeah for instance um let's
say quinium and continue the game but I
don't want to get into this in much
detail the other games are simply too
long and complicated so a pretty
uneventful draw here swidler is having a
very yeah mediocre tournament with lots
of drawers and one loss and actors
stylists have an excellent went or
drawers but he was better in most of the
games he could easily lead the
tournament if he had won the two French
games that he was really winning in okay
next game um what's next let's see let's
do let's do carlton mother screw shocked
the world champion here playing white
and sm expected we had a goon fat on the
board if Carson's going for d for you
can expect the good flat from Grisha
krennel and Bishop g5 is Carlson's
choice this is some young somewhat less
popular line which does not mean it is
necessarily a bad line it's only yeah a
bit dry at times after nighty for White
has a choice can retreat to h4 to f4
very often we get this type of position
after c5 no toilet if he SD takes you
for this is a bit sharper the light can
get back the pawn
this yeah c5 now we very often get this
type of position yeah fairly fairly
typical situation why term in EM get
differing from any other group of
positions as a pawn on d4 supported by
the e porn so the center is not under
such pressure it's got a stable center
on the other hand black has pretty good
pieces and no direct problem the only
piece not doing that much is in fact the
green felt which appeared looking at a
pawn that is very securely protected
Queenie for and Queen 85 also a typical
maneuver black wants to get the Queen's
off before there is too much pressure on
the on the queenside for example white
could do something like this at one
point so we got the Queen's off and in
fact we see master easier on the C file
check yeah and what now draw a grid yeah
and not with Carlton really he continues
from here and in fact he definitely
would get something look at this the
night is nearing the Queen side and
black basically was forced to set up the
position that he has now check out took
on c6 giving up his bishop pair but in
the process especially after this year
have the bishop e8 setting up a position
where this type of setup is not really
attractive black has got this Bishop 1c8
and all pawns on light squares while
white is dominating you with the night
and the bishop on the dark squares so we
have a very one-sided endgame now that
certainly as a position perfectly
tailored for the world champion the
question of avarice was white is
certainly
what better the question is can you
really win it and then I will go through
most moves here quickly here it was
important to keep the night I don't want
to let it exchange against the b6 bishop
so that we got opposite colored bishops
need to keep it on the board and it is
quite remarkable that we got to position
where with those kind of moves right is
very close to winning upon gree shocker
did a very good defensive job I think he
covered f 6 cm bishop f6 and avoid the
trade what black absolutely never can
allow is it's a trade of dark squared
bishop if we for instance hmm I want to
ever have a way to get to to this
configuration without blundering
something but yeah let's say just it
does not really make any sense right
okay I'm still going to do it here white
can win a pawn with 95 with a double
attack but i just wanted to show the
type of position that black should avoid
let's say something like that yeah maybe
even even this year and now black is
totally boxed in with the bishop he
shouldn't trade dark squared bishop
other than okay you can trade it against
the night yet to get opposite colored
bishops but Bishop against bishop
absolutely never as then we have the
pure night advantage against the very
bad bishop okay Grisha actually allowed
to this double attack in order to play
c5 get rid of his weakness at activate
his light squared Bishop this was a very
good defense I think and here it's an
interesting judgment call should why
take f seven or eight seven council
decided to take h7 to get the idea of
bullet generating a passed pawn yeah
it's debatable I don't really think that
night f7 on
it says any any better probably this is
going to be played and black has nicely
activated his position now takes and
it's very difficult to make any headway
here we look at this there is this
important move leading to opposite
colored bishops and this black will draw
quite easily it is very difficult to
really make something out of it I think
and this was played black activated his
Bishop check yeah they always said that
you never should trade the dark squared
bishop here's an exception like now just
calculated this concrete lines took and
f6 this is the concrete idea that i
mentioned if now the night if no other
night moves back change this check
picking up the porn so very much
unadvisable why does going forward to
attack f6 with the check King e7 and now
black is threatening g5 and the nidus
trapped so you cannot can I do this and
you will lose it or queen or to g7
better g5 must be played and the bad
news is we have more more traits yeah
after the capture black also quickly
gets the King in and that's the one
problem the king is Sam is active yes he
hasn't tried it and he keeps a pawn yes
the extra porn but white has the
activity and the bishop and in on this
open board the bishop is a good
defensive piece blacks king is striving
for counter play this whole end game is
really am pretty much dead he continued
for a while there's no reason to call it
a draw yet so can can continue but
objectively speaking there's not
channeling ya know Black is just just
staying with this active pieces and
white has no way forward cannot even
push the edge porn check some some
shuffling yeah I know Black was going
down and here draw was a grid yeah
somewhat typical of cards and started
going for this very slight advantageous
endgame it it was slice for white
certainly but maybe it really wasn't
enough for when I didn't see the press
conference but I think this was
basically what cards and said it was
better all the way but is it winning
probably not angry shocked I think
stated that it was a very uncomfortable
experience to play this game I can very
much see what he's trying to say it's
just just um yeah pure defensive job
never threaten anything in the whole
game not much fun ok the next game to
look at is chronic aronia um chronic
aronia still a match of I guess
disappointed players Kramnik after his
loss pretty much yeah devastating loss
against the part of certainly trying to
to get to get get a full point in fball
we have a Queens gambit rocco's and
again very popular line in this
tournament and it's pretty much unclear
what white should do to to fight for an
advantage chrome nation tries the
exchange and Queenie for check which at
least make sure that the night needs to
go to see 6 where it is slightly
misplaced like would like to have the
the pawn involved in the center of
battle but it's not the end of the world
on the other
and we see that this is played and black
at least has got three piece play the
bishop on c8 for example is so free to
move Bishop f8 and 97 this is just one
set up that a black n can choose there's
also a set up based on bishop e6 a6 and
56 this is actually what what I studied
when I was looking at the real goes and
some time ago i actually had considered
to to play this opening as black and i
played it a couple of times but
ultimately and it didn't become one of
my my main openings not because it was
bad but i had some some other things
that i am that i preferred ok so this
regrouping is to actually be able to
play c6 stabilize the structure and
black has the bishop pair that's nice
but his pieces are somewhat somewhat
clumsily place they need to be a need to
be improved and this is what our own end
is doing he gets rid of the light
squared Bishop and puts the night on b6
hoping to to be a help in fixing the
queenside on keeping the Queen side
together why displaying the typical
minority attack on the queenside very
classic approach it is however a very
miniscule pull that white has 30 typical
what happens here the straight and now
be five yeah this is the way the
minority attack unfolds very often
though you simply have more pieces on
the board and more pieces that actually
if we if we continue a few MOS more
pieces that actually can attack the c6
bomb the whole thing is is really am
very very little that
white hairs but so there were some some
interesting points happening later in
the game funny funny a shot here with
the bishop black must play a 52 to block
this and this is not a move that he he
loves to play really it seems to be
quite a substantial weakness of the
light squares but still the question can
wide really use any of those weaknesses
he tried to check centralized the Queen
ear and in this position in fact after
King f7 white had an interesting
technical shot especially after the
trade this happened and what is an
interesting shot here this is e for
which it first looks really really nice
well okay this is not possible and D
takes e4 after Bishop f1 to c4 probably
also don't want to analyze too deeply it
looks a terrible for black so what about
d4 is this is strong move the thing is
some the Queen does not have any good
squares there is Bishop b6 quite a funny
reply still white can play it you can
take on f5 and take on g6 this is not
winning for white at first it looks very
nice but there is this particular
defense and to be honest I think this
should end in a draw for example if
white now tries to to continue with Luca
d1 lucky even has rook c7 something like
that check
might happen with a completely John rook
endgame before was interesting but
probably ultimately are not sufficient
to to get anything from Nick repeated a
bit and then routed the Queen just back
to the queenside in those kind of
position you basically try to alternate
between various setups trying to keep
the pressure on and wait for chances
that maybe the other side gives you it
also makes sense to to prolong the
gambit and with the the clock ticking
down trying to to to get to new threats
that maybe I'm not easy to handle with
the little time so there was a bit of
shuffling and it's a bit tough for me to
really analyze this it's always clear
that white is is having the better
chances but are you really able to to
break through there was once particular
spot here when Queen B 2 was played here
it seems that Queen B 1 was an
interesting way to play the ideas that
it covers the foursquare and control
contrast to Queen B to the idea is to
play Bishop a for quincy two and then
takes the six this is in fact not so
easy for black to learn to parry 11
possible line if black is not really
doing anything is this Bishop a 436 and
Quincy too yeah okay here's the question
Queenie form is the possible
continuation leading to white being a
quite quite some pawns up but is this
winning it's not totally clear to me
even if we look at this this move well
black just gives up the pawn let's say
for example we do this
knock Bishop b5 and Dwight will get
defiled I'm not totally sure that this
is winning then the whole thing is very
difficult I guess he he missed something
here Kramnik it it really looks like
after f5 has been played and why this
close to getting to the Queen side there
should be something in the game it
fizzled out relatively quickly because
after Queen B to Luke c7 Bishop f4 no
Aronian had the strongest f4 and this
was securing some counter play he takes
a 4 and Bishop h4 very important after
the capture check black is check giving
a perpetual check white cannot escape if
we go see em Jack you believe lose the
game so weiter needed to just continue
Queenie 7 less again a good defense if
white takes check there's Queenie form
again with the perpetual check this is
an important line securing their
perpetual yakking h2 was played check
and now they capture a very very direct
way to to play but also a good way King
takes yeah if it takes with the pawn
check this is a very simple perpetual
check check and this is also securing
enough counter play black is breaking
through yet left on the F farm and now
has three pawns checked this already is
that is pretty much a draw here they
actually greeted agreed upon the draw
yeah a good fighting game I really think
that maybe chronic around 50 of 50
around here maybe you should have gotten
something this f5 is not ideal and maybe
with the NOC precision you will
one or two pounds this queen bee one is
maybe the way to go that also calcium
maybe not sure if it would be sufficient
for win but it certainly am more more
testing continuation than the game where
after Bishop h4 therefore black got
enough counter play okay so what is
still left yeah okay the game yuri
kayaking this is I think officially the
longest game ever I have a show on video
now it's not the game of the day I and
selected another game but I have to warn
you this is so long that lots of it will
be fast forward okay we have this type
of opening again we have seen this
before in some games with Giri being on
both sides now this said d5 where black
is some here setting up a center here if
I've also as possible but kayaking goes
for g6 which is the other way to to set
up the position age for ya quite
commonplace nowadays this kind of move
trying to get an age five quickly or
provoke some sort of yeah answer like
age six and we get a position that can
easily arise from various English
opening structures with reverse colors
in all shapes and sizes White has good
pieces active pieces Black has a good
central control we get this straight and
here like this and black takes with the
Queen yeah and this is in fact quite
interesting after this move now rugby
eighth and ninth c4 we come to a
position where black screen is really
short of squares
and cockiness playing this in a very
straightforward manner in place Bishop
c6 a move that really takes some yeah
some some positional strength to really
consider because at first it looks like
like insanity you're weakening your pawn
structure immensely and the night is is
on c4 ready the ideal square to to
locate the double corn in fact the whole
thing is not not clear at all because
black also has some some positive sides
this is the most important one is got
this rook on the be foul for example I
think the whole position needed to be a
sess differently if white wouldn't have
played a three but be three instead yeah
okay this is just a fiction because I
didn't happen but just to understand the
structure better with the pawn on b3 and
the pawn on a2 b3 is securely protected
and the rook is not doing much while
here there's always pressure on the pawn
and possibly there's also be three as a
weakness the fun thing is this structure
is still totally solid for for both
sides actually and they shuffled around
in the structure for a very very long
time I'm not going to tell you much
about this this is a big shuffle there
are some things happening really but
it's not looking look looking like much
note that we are approaching move 50
already there must be cautious that I'm
not missing anything in fact there are
thumbs something's happening it's not
like they're shuffle until move 200 here
an important important moment kayaking
is putting them
night on b6 and forces at radium white
cannot yeah remove both nights so he
captures and a v6 yeah is this an
accomplishment of like this improvement
of the pawn structure in some way yes on
the other hand look at the rook rook now
has very little maneuvering space and in
fact if we continue a bit and they
really shuffle for a long time check so
the structure is has slowly evolved
white has pushed pawns forward and gain
some space without really getting
anything concrete but if anybody it's of
course white that can do something the
rupee is strapped black cannot really
move it and why it has the somewhat
better minor piece in this very close
structure with the night the night or
ever is also not very mobile but it's a
good it's nicely posted on c4 the next
important thing is happening here black
is attacking the four pawn try to open
up the center of positions so why this
term is closing the position blackest
here returning the exchange or giving up
the exchange at quite a fine situation
the thing is that after look be4 night a
three see to the rook will be lost
anyway or the exchange will be lost it
is not a problem really this route a5
this happened and here we got the the
next and in a way final pawn structure
for the game it looks really weird black
is an exchange down and has this
somewhat awkward pawns but
if you look at this and ask yourself how
actually is life going to win this now
you cannot play before you cannot play
d4 well g4 is also completely protected
this is a typical case where a chess
engine is not telling the whole truth if
you feed at the end to any engine I
tried stockfish try to Deenie it gives
white just plus two and which basically
means a total win the problem is it's it
is not plus two it is very very
difficult to do anything as this has the
fortress-like character this position
they shuffled as you probably have
guests for a long time now the only
question is rising should white at some
point take on d4 I'm going to address
that later because in fact he decided to
take them but only later after yet
shuffled the king over to a2 which is a
good idea the king is protecting the b3
weakness and this is the relatively best
post for the king now we are on the move
100 mark and note that by now they were
down to a very little time playing on
the increment mostly of 30 seconds
spoons there was no big time a reservoir
left for any of them okay and that's not
much happening really it's also probably
to gain a bit of time on the clock and
here he actually give we decided to take
it's probably necessary at some point
you never get anywhere without this
probably a you also never get anywhere
with it but it's the only chance but I
was admit what he did was a very a very
a tough very hard approach and in fact
white got something because he now
played g-form that the only chance
really if you don't do that and if your
feed it to a computer by the way it will
never do that simply because it will
shuffle forever but g4 is a very valid
winning tribe black takes with their
pawn discreetly form and wide we'll take
g6 next or d4 also a possibility on the
right moment but this should be winning
for white so he took with the pawn and
now aged five really breaking through
you need to do something like that
otherwise it keeps totally closed and
white is entering this gets now quite
quite tough to play c5 yeah a tough
decision is this the right move or
should like avoid it the computer
initially suggests that Queen c7 should
be better but Queen to be eight at the
end user is still very strong attacking
here attacking here very tough to hold
this was playing Queen f7 King a6 and
now rook see to this position is in fact
a very very critical one rook see two
turns out to be is a mistake it is very
difficult though to to to assess this
year keeping in mind that both players
are really playing on the increment only
it's very difficult to play this the
problem is after Luke see to pay yakeen
plays Queen c6 and the screen now has
some serious counter-attack and
potential if the rook moves away from
the second-ranked also Queen to d5
sometimes it seems that instead of Roxy
to and the idea is certainly very
logical getting it into the attack on
white should have played a queen e8
first
covering the important squares
especially HC six keeping this attacked
and it seems that this gives white very
very good winning chances probably it
wins brooksy to our ever Quincy six
seems to be a draw according to the
computer at calculates and says okay
there is no winner here anymore black
also has the Jeep on don't forget that
it might prove to be the decisive factor
with with counter play Queen g6 was
played and also keeping an eye on the G
porn and now c4 nice move it wasn't
necessary to play black also could have
played bishops III but this is a very
nice way to continue as it only gives
rise a very uncomfortable choice taking
here check it's quite obviously nice for
black it's it's silly draw but no
problem whatsoever this is in fact even
losing the D porn is far too strong
White will not be able to to stop this
so what is the move Ruby Falls played
check Queen g2 and around here I was
pretty sure that they would agree to a
draw or they would play out the
perpetual yeah check many checks check
ya know there's no check okay no problem
kayaking is returning to d5 his certain
exchange down for porn but he's very
nicely coordinated now the queen is
centralized it supports the G porn and
there is Bishop c3 check at the right
moment yeah King a2 was played white
really is not able to do much in terms
of activity and here
with this pawn detect we are moved 131
um yeah here white should play King a
two and repeat the position however as
mentioned with very little time of the
clock give replayed the rooks e4 and
this turned out to be a very very
unfortunate decision because now
kayaking played bishops III and the
threatening are made in a couple of
movers Queenie for and the worst is for
what there is no way to prevent it it's
a very very unlucky situation why it has
no check and Queenie for is just the
total totally deadly threat what can
also not really a fight with this as now
queen d 1 is threatening with the
maintain a couple of moves so after
Bishop c3 after this is very long fight
of more than seven hours and he resigned
the game very tough loss after 131 moves
he tried very hard to win but at the end
um yeah made this this blunder with a
little time on the clock and probably
being somewhat exhausted be played its
nicely with g4 h5 creating chances out
of this very closed end not very
attractive position but yeah also very
tough defensive job ok I can do with
this win is now actually um also on +1
in in contention in this and this
tournament okay so now for the game of
the day this is
I need to click it correctly kawana the
ball off it's a bit of a mysterious game
I'm saying this right away okay so
kawana is going formed efore mainline
openings again he is mixing it sometimes
playing closed opening with mostly it's
a four main line and to follow this
going for his fairly standard night off
yeah and f3 being played not Bishop e3
the typical move for the englisha tech
maybe because the part of also places so
white is directly avoiding the whole
business yeah not the power of place an
old favorite that is played the number
of times this quickie 6b five and even
before this he had played before and
yeah could could have been anticipated
in a way also some of them get on the
main second of two polyps even know
Jabari know if he also had played this
line a number of times so something that
Kara wanna really could could expect but
he invested already some time here and
after 97 he cancelled long yeah the
whole thing is very complicated
obviously but here is still a chance to
play it in a yeah in a somewhat more
sedate manner with c4 this will probably
would probably be be my choice if you
give this position to me I would chicken
out and not Castle long c4 is still
quite quite a decent choice black will
take and after Bishop d7 and d5 half
half decent equalizing chances this for
example had been played in a game island
to parlor in 2006 but long castles is
the sharpest move Queen a five and now
we see that we get a very very unusual
position
night hangs b3 the only move there
should be seven and a three and this is
really quite funny what is black
supposed to do there is this threat and
black has no a really good way to to get
out of this yeah move like d5 is
unfortunately being answered by e5 and
all this gets very ugly with Bishop b6
quite a nice motive actually Queen c7
and a before being played yeah this
looks really weird right but this has
been played a number of times and I'm a
bit surprised that koala here is after
those move spending lots of time look at
this 147 spent almost 30 minutes on this
move and this is quite remarkable as
this position already had been played by
chip arena and if you prepare for the
part of you also have to check the
second scheme of course and it is also a
main part of the palace repertoire so
it's quite surprising that kawana
usually being superbly prepared has
nothing really yet to show him he took
on a six and basically had to work it
out over the board I guess yeah Bishop
a6 and 95 the whole situation is of
course very very sharp why does a pawn
up but has a totally untidy position
with the poor Nia on b3 the night on the
rim Bishop a 3some times coming with
with the tempo yeah black must take this
this is clear and now default it's only
also the only move that really makes
some sense yeah in this position here
also there is just one move that white
can play and this is the piece
price at karana took some time for that
but he absolutely must do it if white is
not doing that and tries to play
something like this keeping keeping the
poorer leaf on deform black is playing
the check with the temple and then
castles with Luke ba to follow this is
just for one mere pawn a fantastic
initiative from blacking our fantastic
attack whatever you want to call it it's
just excellent for black and therefore
white must sacrifice the piece it's not
a decision to be taken lightly giving up
the dark squared bishop when you are
already weak on the dark squares and
this reward theme is indeed an important
factor look a five the move very
interesting attacking the bishop from
the side by the way instead of Queen D
for white also had the option to play me
five and this is maybe actually the
battles then queen d4 d5 is very a very
sharp black now only has one reply needs
to attack the b5 Bishop you cannot
really move any of the nights and it's
this is pinned the Queen cannot take
because of rupee one and yeah you don't
want to move the f6 night after Queen D
for that looks really really ugly so you
must counter-attack with luke a 50 rupee
eight and after that we could get to
this generation very very complicated
stuff in fact you can continue this line
for one there are many many options um
one could be to just take here and
playing with the idea of F for this is
an interesting position and probably
really unclear what what has two points
for the piece but still an attack or two
points sf6 or three points technically
speaking but it's a it's a very very
complicated
position may be better than the game and
in the game after rugae five white
really am yeah has some trouble how do
you handle the situation that the bishop
is hanging taking on this happen it's
not really doing much good as you want
to yeah keep the pinner life but how do
you do that he tried Queen d3 to keep
this in the game check Bishop e3 check
king be one interesting situation here
black also could have castled but this
is probably less precise if we look at
this Bishop d7 root Jade White has the
strong wolf Quincy three unpinning and
trading down to such an endgame here
it's probably not advisable here why
does better with this horns under the
King supporting it it's not a position
that I would like to have us black
tamala played king in seven this yeah so
somewhat brave move if you have castles
as an alternative but why not the king
is relatively safe yeah it's on a dark
square so the dark square weaknesses
that white has meaning that this Bishop
is simply protecting all the important
square so why does not have really a
great attack took on d 7 I don't really
see much else to be honest 97 and 93 may
be here again Queens III was an idea
this is the worst version of the endgame
of course as some in comparison here
black has far better coordinated but
maybe it was still what Y term should
should try in the game he played 93 and
this is really not really not leading to
a good position but here we come to the
absolutely mysterious part of the game
okay more consider this position kawana
is down to 13 minutes around and to pull
off celess a ton of time in our seven
minutes so he could easily spend ten
minutes 20 minutes if you want and still
have a substantial time advantage okay
look at the position what is white
threatening it's a very simple 95 check
about everybody and the uncle will see
that and the mysterious thing is what is
the most natural move to to cover the
the check yeah Knight b6 them why not
not be 6 it's covering the check it's
getting the night out of this attack on
the default and there is absolutely no
apparent great continuation for white in
fact if you give this to to an engine of
your choice it will already show
something between minus two and minus
three the whole position is for y term
is absolutely terrible for white as the
dark squared weaknesses will tell for
example it's like to try something like
that you have always this possibility to
drop the bishop back maybe not the most
precise move actually this could be the
move to start with so that black
actually has King f8 if possible but
what I'm getting at is the light squares
here or this is wrong the dark squares
here on the white side are very weak and
if we just imagine the bishop joining
the tech or wire be for c3 this is
deadly absolutely deadly white will not
survive this this attack on his King 95
is however very a cooperating in a way
this is a bit more tricky but there's
Quincy five attacking the knight and if
it drops back there is g 6 i'm not
saying that this is totally easy to see
calculate and evaluate but the strange
thing is here to pull off really has
of time you can easily spend as mention
10 or 20 minutes to try to evaluate this
and instead he just plays in two minutes
the move 95 and just completely throws
the way all advantage after this only
white can be better and I absolutely
don't understand what he's doing here
195 is totally obvious what else is
there and now black must give up the
exchange so instead of playing with a
piece for three points and then attack
he is an exchange yeah he has given up
the exchange here so that we now have
rook and three pawns against two minor
pieces normally the two minor pieces am
in the middle of game in the middle game
type of position are quite nice but here
in this concrete situation it's not easy
at all as the pieces due to lack of
pawns don't really have that that stable
squares it's a it's not so easy to play
Queen c3 maybe this was the initial idea
it's just blonde yang due to the check
and whatever like ass going right here
that's probably even a check chant or h8
hangs but the main thing is you lose the
bishop iam so Queen c3 is not possible
yeah play droop see a door very quickly
c4 and Bishop c5 yeah the thing is that
black still has this bad King position
to play against and if we consider this
determined it at first I thought well
shouldn't this be good for white with
the three pawns you can three pawns I
think there are circumstances where
white would be really substantially
better and this is Queen trade without
any deterioration of the pawn structure
if white can trade queens and keeps the
structure it would be excellent for him
the problem is it is may
not easily possible in the game King aid
was a strong news he invested 20 minutes
and this was a strong move I mean
sometimes it really helps if you think a
bit about your moves yeah Queenie a king
yet is a very strong moving over to part
of the ideas to plain 97 and possibly 26
to 36 this was the wrong arrow going
here or maybe to default depending on
circumstances and here it is very tricky
now to play something else than what
kawana played and I probably think that
kawana saw the game continuation and
considered okay maybe I cannot win this
but at least I'm not going to lose it he
was certainly aware that he had losing
position some moves ago um I decided to
play rook t3 why is this a far-reaching
decision yeah because of 97 and now your
queen is attacked where where should you
put it there only really good square is
he five trading Queens I'm going
somewhere off-site is probably not
advisable when black is starting to to
go near the king he played Queenie 5 and
the sudden he wants the plan getting rid
of the Queen's yeah black traded and
plate 96 this is what i meant a queen
trade without any pawn structure
deterioration here if I've is gone and
e4 as weak so this end game that we get
now with was f6 it's not as advantageous
as it could have been for white on could
have been as the wrong expression as
white would have wished wished it to be
with a good pawn structure here black in
fact has good squares for the pieces
especially the night the night only five
is of course excellent and at the moment
is not easy for why to get those pawns
rolling
and probably the whole thing is about
equal now they are however played on for
very long time both being a very
competitive players it's not like I'm
like a straight to we know anything but
check it's no reason to agree to a draw
yeah white must try to somewhat
organizes his rooks and King to get the
pawns rolling but it's not easy check
like by now is very nicely coordinated
check now we can go on a bit because the
in fact was some change in the structure
yeah quite managed to get to get some
headway here but black in the meantime
covered up the h2porn and hereafter be
five we have a chat a transformation now
whiter gets in to g7 but we'll lose the
sea porn in the process it's a simply
not much left only those two pawns yeah
GM check they agreed to draw the game
Luke f6 is what white can can still play
but then Bishop e7 looking at 596 by now
at the right moment you can also just
give up one of the pieces against the
porn and draw for example here if black
once you can can simply take here and
draw and draw this position can can be
done quite easily as you reach the the
corner but it's not possible they're not
necessary really I also wouldn't have
done that just go back here the age
point is it's not really dangerous at
the moment
so a very mysterious game to power off
could easily have gotten good chances to
win the game if he had not played 95
instantly but went for Knight b6 and
after that it's very tough to give white
some advise it seems yeah as it happened
can in the game we got this end game
which is probably about equal and which
was drawn pretty convincingly by 2 pi
love so yeah good and interesting fight
but still strange why 95 was played
almost immediately instead of night to
be 60 maybe a somewhat lucky escape here
for marijuana ok I hope you enjoyed the
coverage for around seven we have only
two rounds left and in fact before the
final two rounds there will be a rest
day so no coverage on on Wednesday the
tournament situation now is quite quite
funny as we have four players on +1
kayaking prom Nick caruana and Carlton
so four players are shared first and
there are even two players with fifty
percent Grigio and actor stein and they
both have some slight chances as well of
course especially an artist and could
easily have been on plus two he has got
seven drawers which is an excellent
result but could easily have won two
games okay I hope you enjoyed it I'll be
back with coverage for around eight on
on thursday that is thanks for watching